est-ce pas là
[Musique]
john paul ringo et djordje l'efap fort
au complet était au cirano de versailles
le vendredi 13 janvier
ou plutôt leurs sosies de boucler
beatles le groupe de reprises à rejouer
le lay mythique de 1964 premier concert
de peter en france dans cette même salle
mon seul study of vd a enrichi sa blonde
et moi avons étudié les vidéos et
évidemment mémoriser la manière dont ils
se conduisaient sur scène la façon de
tenir leurs instruments la façon aussi
de bouger leur tête de parler à leur
public
le plus important c'est ensuite de
pratiquer pendant des mois pour un
résultat parfait tu peux fight
considéré comme le meilleur tribute band
du combo anglais de bootleg little a
tourné dans le monde entier depuis sa
création en 1978 ce concert anniversaire
était leur premier hors région
parisienne
le public leur a réservé un accueil
chaleureux
les beatles extraordinaire ils ont
réussi à faire lever tout le monde à
faire danser tout le monde dans le
tyranneau donc exceptionnel avec cette
ambiance là franchement c'est la
première fois qu'on a le feu comme ça ou
serrano chance je pense qu'ils étaient
très intelligents dans l'écriture de
leurs chansons et semblait par là une
très large audience les écrivais
constamment de bonnes chansons c'est ça
qui a cédé beatles les beatles de twist
and shout
un ticket to ride la hit machine a
conquis les spectateurs versaillais de
bouclettes beatles reviendra en juin
avec une tournée française pour les 50
ans de l'album
certes on peut peut-être
[Musique]